hello and welcome to gamespot plays
black mesa i'm here with Danny O'Dwyer
playing one of his favorite games and
wearing his favorite headcrab yeah
that's that's my boy Lamar we're playing
black mesa and man look at this for a
black mesa right here we already made
one yeah this is the i guess feels like
the third iteration of this this is a
mod for half-life 2 which is attending
to recreate 1998 half-life 1 and this
was available years ago i played this
years ago it was finished all the way up
to zen but uh well you know more about
this it just came in on early access
yeah so they just released it on early
access I believe two days ago and I mean
basically it's it's similar to what you
would have downloaded if you got it
before it was on early access they've
included a multiplayer mode which is
sort of the big like reason you'd pay
twenty dollars it's I mean it's
basically half life to death match but
half life 1 feet would you have liked to
that the half I've won that match was
not back right yes it's kind of a weird
edition are they added a bunch of like
graphical features as well cuz this kind
of looks a bit better than so I mean the
the main reason you want black mesa in
general is because they've completely
redone the textures all the graphics are
new the lighting effects are new look at
that guy is giving you a slide look for
a man being given CPR yeah apologies for
waiting here but i have completed i can
run through half-life 1 and 2 in my
brain from start to finish I've guy
could weaken every year I'm I'm just so
interested in like the granularity
because in half-life 1 if you wait this
guy gets up oh really yeah he saves him
oh my god it doesn't take that long I
could take a sec next ones when he
should actually get up that's why he's
giving you that look he's fine he's like
he's lucky he's waiting for the keel was
a lotta and no air some dead eyes that
reveal that might be the g-man existing
pasta I don't think he's gonna go I
don't know it doesn't look like he's
getting up is all of course is all
physics happen now yes I could just pick
up this video tape and be like no you
Jesus Madison this is Madison so it's
interesting because they've used the
physics to add in a lot of than like so
you know half-life original has like a
lot of those little bits where like
there's the guy in the bathroom stall
who just kind of cost if you had to open
the door on him so now that guy is
saying that he's run out of toilet paper
and it's like oh like is anyone out
there
if you grab a roll of paper towels and
throw it to him he thanks you and you
get an agreement yeah that is great it's
absolutely hilarious so there's a lot of
little like I mean like this is new
clearly you couldn't get this this
detritus away before and that was
something I noticed the first of it's
been a while since I've played this or
whatever this was previously and and
that was one of the interesting things
is that it's not a one-to-one copy of
apartheid yeah they have actually there
are segments which we may get to later
where they literally have taken part
side and put other parts in yeah and I
mean there's it's not like a major story
change like you know Eli Vance isn't
gonna die right now or anything but and
also that's cool because like I know is
like a massive half-life and that this
was hui lai Vance was yes and that
that's who dr. kleiner was but I
wouldn't have known in the game the
great office like retcon the story for
half-life 2 yeah but in this they've
like straight-up pony lion with like
hair and look he's got both legs yeah
yeah before it was just like generic
white scientist genera african american
scientist actly i'm like you saw them
repeated over and over again exactly
yeah now they're actually like they
retrofitted the game to have that and
hint a little more at half life 2 also
there's a lot of like little weird jokes
and added dialogue they've rerecorded a
bunch of VO for it Wow so there's a good
joke where when you walk in some guys
like oh Gordon you cut the ponytail sell
out just these weird implications about
gordon freeman before half life by i see
you see with black may cease it a couple
years see you with a city 17 oh lordy i
remember this bit guys just screaming
for his life as gordon freeman calmly
crouches in the corner yes sir i don't
think he was in this in half like point
i didn't the door was either it hits it
my oh my god with some physics enable
death happen they didn't blew that man
apart this is all my favorite parts of
the game is when you you meet your first
headcrab in like the wet area yeah just
slipping around and there's like this
one head cobb and you've gotten looking
to kill them with so like this is new
like this that this is a new take on
that area here and another interesting
thing about this part of the game is
since it's before you have your crowbar
or any guns or any way to stop these
amies before it was kind of like you got
to grab a guard and just basically hope
that they shoot the zombies yeah now
they've added this thing we're there
these lit like emergency flares
everywhere
and you can remove them up and throw
them and there's like gas leaks that you
can light on fire to kill zombies you
can read it directly at a zombie oh
that's cool yeah you'll see in a minute
actually it's actually really cool
because it's nice to be able to you know
stop them yourself and I just run around
it is my favorite gags from half-life 1
this is so is the body here oh it just
happened there and just like split up
yeah so in the original one that goes up
the wall and comes down and you're like
you're looking at it going oh no oh no I
know when it hits the body it just like
Gabe's everywhere man see I it's been so
long since I played half life that when
i was playing this the other day I was
like this is it's all coming back to me
but I can't remember like what's new and
what's just like half-life redone I
wonder if this guy is still here so in
the original is it the elevator yeah
when you hit the button they I think
it's AI think i'm pretty sure does it
without hitting the button do though how
do you know screaming in the other you
remembered that i don't think so oh all
right that's what smashes it open you
should go down the ladder and like look
at what happened to those people cuz
there were like four people in an
elevator so I went down to see like
maybe someone survive no it was super
crying it's like a pizza in the original
you came down here there was a HEV suit
oh really how rabia 15a him suit oh
there was like a su dia power module or
whatever over here first bit of shield
his where he came from oh sorry guys I
got one more level I'm the half five
expert at all man you're just you're
thrown off by having to see four people
crushed into 1 inch pizza that's new as
well loading screen wasn't there before
Oh loading screen for this section was
on the rotating elevator a mark a
photographic society playbill you really
have played this game a lot and Oh paper
it's gone sup man am I glad to see you
said have obvious got different Barney
textures as well because there was no
African American Barney's in there was
an office yeah one asking yep they got
this guy it's emerald green eyed man
come with me bro please help kill some
zombies zombies zombies gonna get up
yeah yeah they are get it once you have
a Deadhead crab too we need to show off
like a weird physics thing that happens
in this where you can just like smash
courses again stuff oh really oh my god
it's so weird
so after that guys grabbed one of the
Dead headcrabs she pick him up and just
bang it against the wall ya rag oh yeah
I'm getting up it's the bank grab art
hey what's going on oh sorry man i was
he gonna freak out I don't think so he's
like dude that is so gross it's like
there's literally no way for me to kill
a movie my name is oh he's just like oh
dude oh god is so rude see these are the
players so grab one of those and learn
what these were an outlet to see a
little i know i get the light up i
picked up a little on i'm sure you'll be
fine i spark it all right push it there
you go alright now throw it right if
there's a gas leak right there oh really
yeah it's like right now [ __ ] [ __ ]
you'll be fine you're fine [ __ ] right
there yeah here we go sorry Barney see
you inhale Barney see the best thing is
if he dies I got his gun yeah just let
him die yeah he's fighting a flaming
zombie anyone come after me now fix it
barney is not doing a very resilient
gentleman he is I mean he's not shooting
much though he's just looking at horror
and what he's done there's this one line
he says where he's like he's like what
are these things and what are they all
dress like scientists and you're like oh
dude those are like all your coworkers
like I'm real sorry to be the one who's
bearing the bad news to you but those
are your friends and loved ones I think
it just got set on fire though like this
one of the nice touches like this whole
areas was not there yeah I think you
could go in there and talk to those
people before I went to [ __ ] and like
you said earlier they had like a bunch
of extra cool little gags yeah the this
is new like I was I don't know what he
was doing to that guy before it was just
to do it like spinning in the the chair
let's go in to the hey TV room just to
see if there's before there was a power
canister here yet Oh still there I'm his
baby oh it's a different baby picture
it's probably one of the dads babies oh
god that's the guy who was pooping the
man who was poop Oh what has become of
him oh if only he had toilet paper and
could have left what's that it was
beyond am you gave him a good toilet
experience I've stayed there's like
doing I'm just gonna skip the day in
here
you jerk so one thing I hope that we get
to in this is a the music is all
different Eliza and it's completely
redone I wish I could remember the
dude's name because it's so good i want
to give him props but i'll put in the
description for this video cool but you
can download the whole soundtrack for
free it's on soundcloud true and it's so
good and like like I liked the original
music and a half life because it sort of
feels like dated now and sort of like
yeah like you know like neo electronic
of the 90s but it's like it's so good
now it's so atmospheric and like it just
feels so much more cinematic it's weird
it feels that's the most updated thing
in my opinion like it looks good but
sounds better I'm totally peacing out on
Barney because I just want a speed run
through this whole second this is
actually all new the way they introduce
this this isn't how you got the crowbar
the first time how do you I was try to
remember how did in the first yeah you
pick it up way earlier I picked you
picked it up in one of the office
complex parts got it because you didn't
have I don't think he came that far or
the flare sex by the flare section you
had it okay and that guy's really not
mention up oh this guy's great remember
he fights the headcrab and then he's
like I killed it when he throws the
piece on yeah and then he's like and
then it comes through like the ceiling
or something I was one behind it oh oh
that's so brutal oh here's the guy in
the chair yeah because the chair he's
got the blue screen situation he's got
more problems than that dude HL 2 dot
exe it's pretty good that's really funny
highrise see those little things like
that like you can just tell these dudes
love half life and like I mean like you
said they've reinterpreted a lot of
things about this game yeah and that's
what makes it cool it's not just like
beautiful half-life 1 it's like a fans
reimagining of half-life 1 but with all
the great things impact another little
tiny part here was that this guy was
alive healthy original anita's tells you
you need to go through here and oh no
was he I think he was I think that was
one of the guys you could like crowbar
to get his gun that's even more brutal
this is a different that's a different
sound there as well yeah it is so this
was the era this is like the start of
the next chapter from right oh look
they've actually put in like a new
physics puzzle physics puzzler it's
crazy but I'm not much of a puzzle but I
give it a half-life 2 yeah so this is
office complex now things yeah I think
so we're getting close we're getting
close to the headcrab elevator oh yeah
but favorite pie and we'll get to see
some hound eyes here as well which are
about
oh yeah favorite dudes from the first
game they're just the best it's also
cool having the the four deghans be the
Vorta gan skins from a flight do yeah
because I was like I saw him come out I
was like a new other enemies in this
game but like maybe they're not and then
they start shooting lightning at me when
I totally still are that's so weird yeah
cuz I was like oh I'm the chosen one
remember like half-life 2 and I'm like
wait doesn't happen often do they know
you're not to free that yeah exactly had
this is crazy because this is like
totally different as well this a way
this looks here I'll have to replay
half-life 1 after applying this a bit
yeah they do it'll probably be a trip
like yeah look at this nonsense it is
non cod sama drink a cold one in here
while your we'd wait for this thing to
blow over I'm an extra cold one I guess
they just have a lot more environmental
stuff they can do this time range yeah
no one glass happening in them I feel
like a lot of the things that they did
in Black Mesa are things that like the
original debs would have done for
half-life 1 if there was physics puzzle
availability at the time like i like i
guess if you just remake a cold Jesus
you just crowbar to spark that ignited
the whole room just wanted to see the
hand by so bad you know what your
passion is undermined the safety of this
mission well I got your girl you're
right you like you what they could have
done is like Donna 121 and like left
behind you know a 16 years of whatever
of gameplay evolution especially what
happened since half life 2 yeah all the
physics stuff so what they've done is I
kind of craft something that is a
difficult balance of like trying to keep
it memorable but totally fresh yeah I
honestly wonder I bet there were some
interesting conversations about like
ideas that went too far yeah I bet I bet
somebody left yeah but they're like [ __ ]
this isn't what I signed up for I wanted
to make them oh [ __ ] you this is the you
know I wanted to make the the original
yeah ducted does HD the security team
hanging up this is dude still here
worthy yeah I'll get out of there oh no
I was great my god that's a book come
out again wow that was brutal done they
made quick work of that man's honey pots
hmm oh yeah look at that chicken wing oh
oh it's just floppy oh god it just shove
it back up there yeah
you met sorry i miss my god sorry well
that's all right oh come get it shall we
leave it there Jeremy yeah it spot for
this is half-life yeah again and it's on
early access and it's so it's free how
does it work so it's 1999 for they guess
man I thought paying mods was gone
what's happening I guess they found a
workaround I guess so I mean this is I
mean technically speaking it is its own
game yeah it used to be yeah exactly
certain is Ahmad it's now grown enough
that they feel like they can judge me by
charging money for it was a g-man and
you're right they've been working on
this for I think like I would hazard a
guess it's something like seven years
dude it i think it's like shortly after
whoa like half-life 2 they probably
started this because this is this has
been around for a long time these hands
are great yeah they have done a great
job of remaking the hammock looking out
yeah the visual effects a really nice
tripping balls on hand eyes o.o beat
that guy it looks like a ugly little pug
that's gonna cut the head off pick him
up ma Sherman's people's faces wish
sadly mom that would be excellent so in
1999 and woke up there it doesn't have
zaniness right but right so the zen
chapters are still missing but you get
multiplayer you get everything up till
then and it's a reimagined version of
half-life 1 so what more could you
really ask for love it thanks Jeremy
forgive me an excuse to play half-life 1
all over again my pleasure man excellent
yeah thanks for watching guys stay tuned
for more gamespot plays really not this
game but more games where the Margo Oh
Lamar say goodbye to the folks Lamar
you